this morning jack carr a former navy
seal turned best-selling thriller writer
carr grew up surrounded by books and
obsessed with the idea of serving his
country he is two for two turning both
of his dreams into reality
carr's latest book in the blood
featuring his hero james reese is out
now distributed by atria an imprint of
paramount global that follows the
release of an amazon prime series the
terminal list which was based on carr's
first book
but cara is facing challenges that now
go beyond the battlefield or a blank
page
to get the full picture we took aim with
him
at his mountain home in park city utah
nice hit
yeah
at 8 000 feet elevation
jack carr
let fly
as usual
he hit the target right in there nice
all right including on request
one that was not planned take out the
camera
what is that a gopro up there yeah take
it out see all right with deepest
apologies gopro do it
how does the camera look oh my god
oh that's rad
no way
it is here in the wasatch range of the
rocky mountains that carr keeps his
innumerable skills sharp i've had this
dictionary since probably yeah yeah yeah
it has that exact same one yeah it'll be
like somewhere around there but you can
tell it's been used quite a bit over the
years carr's mom was a librarian
he devoured thrillers as a kid including
the works of tom clancy ian fleming and
nelson demille
inside his home
you don't need to look far to see those
influences i have things on cia kind of
up here on the top part things iraq and
afghanistan go up over there more
revolutionary war stuff world war one
world war ii
car decided he wanted to be a navy seal
when he was seven
in part inspired by his grandfather who
was shot down and killed in world war ii
carr served 20 years in the military
with deployments to iraq afghanistan the
philippines and more
in 2018 he released his first book the
terminal list featuring a navy seal
named james reese who goes on a revenge
spree following the brutal killings of
those closest to him how much of james
reese is jack carr
very similar background
in that we were both prior enlisted seal
snipers and at some point we become
officers and
in this first novel you meet him when
he's on his last deployment while it was
still in its early stages
carr was already dreaming of the
terminal list being turned into a movie
or tv series you need to understand
something
i have 12 men flying home in caskets
right now which just happened
eight episodes on amazon prime
featuring chris pratt
this is lieutenant commander james reese
you need to send patrol units to 423
cayman street you know i thought when i
started down this path that you could
just go to a cabin in the mountains and
write and send your book to new york and
start your next one maybe you'd get an
interview on cbs and then you just
continue on writing your novels i had no
idea that you had to do everything you
would have to do for any business for
any startup all right so the book tour
updates are on the website manual i
needed a website and i knew i needed to
have a social media presence of some
sort thank you my friend all right go do
your book signing all right let's do
books go to the reagan library all right
but it'll lead up to that publication
for whatever reason i took a breath and
looked at the battle space essentially
that's what i do and uh you know you
look for how to capitalize on momentum
you know you look at gaps in the enemy's
defenses you look how to adapt
and so i looked at this space and
thought oh what can i do that authors
couldn't have done 30 years ago
an unboxing i think i know it's in here
in this clip we talk about the power of
books and stories to impact cultures
around the world today that includes a
growing podcast this will be the library
but this is the podcast studio um
right now
this typewriter right here hemingway's
typewriter he wrote a movable feature
really yeah
carr just published his fifth james
reese book in the blood in may
but his writing has a purpose beyond
just fulfilling a lifelong ambition
one of his three kids has severe special
needs
when his middle child a son was born
it took car and his wife years
fruitlessly searching for answers
until they got a call from a former
presidential candidate
it's ross perot
and he sounds exactly like dana carvey
impersonating ross perot on saturday
night live in the 90s and what what is
going on like ross perot's what yeah
yeah so he calls and he says hey
so and so-and-so and i didn't even know
the name uh told me about your son and
uh we're gonna fix your son he says and
uh he said i'm gonna send the jet and
we're gonna put a team of specialists
together here in dallas and we're gonna
fix them and then like hangs up
essentially
turns out perrault who died in 2019 had
for years been quietly devoting his vast
wealth to help military families
carr's son became only the 13th person
in the world to be officially diagnosed
with a rare disorder of the nr2f1
gene
which causes incurable developmental
delays
he will need 24 7 care for the rest of
his life he's a sweet little guy you met
him and he makes jokes and and he smiles
and and everything but uh but you know
but when you think too far ahead you
know it can be daunting uh because you
have to essentially make sure that
someone is set up for the best medical
care possible for 100 years
so for me when i'm out there and i'm
writing these books and i'm doing all
that's why i'm i'm so driven because
that's a large financial
commitment i don't want that to fall on
his brother or sister so i want that to
be all all set up for him before my wife
and i move on you're doing all this
for him
that's the uh the drive i'll sleep a lot
better at night when uh when his trust
is fully funded and i know that uh if
something happens to me tomorrow that
he'll be taken care of forever do you
miss being overseas being in the field
you know i can ask that question and
you're supposed to say that you miss it
or you miss the guys or whatever else
but i don't and i think that's because i
knew my tactical time was over there's
nothing i could do to change that
and also my family needed me and i knew
exactly what i wanted to do next which
is write novels like this
hmm
hard not to like jack harper i know and
it sounds like he's living
his dream and it had he has a mission
behind it absolutely now especially with
his son raising a wonderful family
in utah um and i i have to say again
here apologies to gopro
it's not jack's fault uh it didn't it
does not make it
let's be clear jeff being jeff we
clearly dared him but it was the first
shot he took there it is but you know
he's a marksman that's right
he is a sniper he seems like he goes
full force into everything he does
absolutely